[Music]
there's a new beer in your hometown of
Austin Texas right Austin Texas and yes
it's come out with a new beer and this
is pretty exciting because in Texas
actually yeah okay Alamo Drafthouse the
theater chain mm-hmm it just came up
with this it's amazing and it's called
everybody wants some beer and it's got
your name on it
unbelievable oh yes don't don't tell me
I haven't achieved something in this
world question have my name on a beer
you've had have action figures you can
put my name on a beer you've had five
Oscar nominations know is having your
own beer absolutely and it's good it's
good beer too little tall boy action
yeah I like it I'm convinced I'm keeping
this this movie is based on a bunch of
college years knowledge years for these
guys and you can relate to this because
this is around the time that you were
going to I was in college at this moment
no was and you maintain that that was
the best time to go to college around
1979 1980 do you think that was like a
perfect time to be in Kabul looking back
it was definitely a good time you know I
didn't think that at the time of course
but you know looking back I think
College got so expensive now there's all
this anxiety around it back then the
stakes were pretty low you know and it
was pre a lot of things free you know
just say no reagan-era pre-aids pre you
know you can go on and on but it was a
kind of the end of the 70s sort of this
anytime did this innocent period it was
a in a pretty unabashedly domestic crazy
time so I look back and go that was a
pretty good time we have time yeah fine
illogically to end up in college so yeah
you just bummed out a lot of college
students watching I mean you depress you
but uh you know it was pretty sure that
you had the cast who the ideas they're
all supposed to be very close they're
baseball players they're all living
together in these two houses and it's so
to get them prepared for that you had
them live on one bunk house yeah I have
a bunk house believe you have a bunk
house on your property yeah I have some
land a little farm outside of Austin
where I live and I built this bunk house
a lot of bunk beds so I told the whole
cast you're all gonna live together for
a few weeks and
we're just gonna work on the movie
rehearse workshop so they live together
just ate every meal together you know
just they really bonded it was is this a
bunkhouse that is used for anything the
rest of the time when actors aren't
using it yeah but it's always a bunch of
cowboys show up yeah you can yeah
working on the ranch you know
no it's for like guests and actually I
got it I built it because I had I'd have
parties out there and friends were
getting like DWIs driving back into town
so I was like am i legally liable I
thought I provide a bunk bed for people
if they weren't able to drive so that's
why it originally existed but it's it's
a you know my daughter's have my
daughters I just want to make sure I'm
not legally like yeah I don't the real
thing oh just you know but the more
drunk people sleep in and off at your
house the better
you